المترجم: Sarah Saad
المدقّق: Anwar Dafa-Alla
البدايات غالبا ما تكون صعبة.
وغالبا ما تكون أكثر من صعبة.
في كل مرة، تأتي عبارة دائما
سمعتها أكثر من مرة
عندي لك فكرة تدر الذهب.
كم مرة مرت عليك
هذه العبارة في حياتك؟
لا يلام الشخص...
على ذمة (بروس ديفيس)
نحن نفكر في 50000 فكرة في اليوم.
المشكلة ليست هنا
82% من هذه الأفكار
فكرنا بها في الأمس.
ومازلنا نعيد نفس الفكرة
ونكررها.
في إحتمالية أن الإنسان
يعيش مع فكرة واحدة 20 سنة.
تخيل عقدين من عمرك
كان راح مع فكرة
لمدة عشرين سنة.
وما السبب؟
غالبا الأفكار عندما تكون موجودة
لا نتخذ أي شيء بخصوصها.
نتركها
في الـback process عندنا.
أرجع أفكر فيها
وأعيد التفكير فيها.
دون أن أبدأ
في شيء حقيقي.
وما السبب؟
عدم وجود هدف.
في فكرة
رأيت مكانا أعجبني
concept جديد
منتج جديد
خدمة جديدة
لم أكن أعرف عنها
أعجبتني.
اتخذت فيها قرار؟
بنيت بها منتج؟
أبدا.
فعدم وضوح الهدف
لا يجعل للفكرة أي قيمة.
سآخذكم إن شاءالله
في تجربة معي
على الخدمات التي عملنا عليها
مع شباب ريادة الأعمال.
وسأطرح لكم التصور
من أين بدأو
وأين انتهو.
الأفكار بكل بساطة
عندما تبدأ
تحتاج إلى أشخاص مبادرين.
غالبا المبادر
ناهيك أنه مصاب ADHD
لأنه دايما ماشاء الله hyper active
يتكلم بسرعة تستطيع ملاحظته
بين الجموع دائما يتكلم بسرعة
دائما ما لا يستطيع
أن يركز أفكاره مع كلامه
دائما منطلق
غالبا ما يهاب
متحدي
صحيح أنه يتورط ثلاثة أرباع الوقت
إلا أنه في البداية
وبدون خبرة تجده يحاول
تستطيع أن تلاحظه اليوم
زميلك المجاور لك فيمقعد الدراسة
تراه غدا في العمل
أو من أصدقائك
تجده إنسان كثيرالتجارب
كثير الأخطاء
لكن مالذي تخلق منه
هذه الأخطاء؟
تخلق الخبرة.
ما يحتاجه للفكرة القادمة
لتنجح.
اليوم نتكلم كثيرا
عن ريادة الأعمال.
والـentrepreneurship
وسهولة وألوان
ونجاحات في ثلاث أربع دقائق
على application ، وصّلنا للقمة.
الموضوع ليس بهذه البساطة
في سنوات مضت
في الم، في عرق
في دموع
في خسارة أصدقاء
في خسارة علاقات
ليصلو
إلى ما وصلوا إليه اليوم.
الإسان المبادر هذا
حتى لو كانت أفكاره موجوده
وقادرعلى بنائها
في مرحلة معينة
في حال إن صعب عليه التواصل
وضعقت عنده الـ communication skills
أو مهارات التواصل
غالبا ما يحتاج لفريق
يعاونه في البناء
إذا كانت عندك خبرة معينة
إذا كان عندك مهارة معينة
المهارة هذه، لا تصنع منك
صاحب عمل.
أو صاحب شركة
أو صاحب مبادرة.
غالبا أنت تحتاج لفريق
ليبني معك.
في كتاب لـ(جيربر)
اسمه The E-Myth Revisited
يتكلم فيه كيف أن أكثر
مشاريع الـCup cake
التي تفشل في أمريكا
سببها...
أن صانعة الـcup cake
التي تمتلك قطة جميلة
غير قادرة على إدارة مشروع
يتحمل تسويق
إختيار مواقع
مالية، وتفاصيل أخرى كثيرة
لم تكن ببالهم عندما بنو الـbusiness
ثاني نقطة
في المشاريع الريادية
الفريق عندك بمثابة الأخ
هو جزء منك أو أكثر
هو بمثابة ذراعك اليمين
ذراعك اليسار
بعضهم بصرك الذي تبصر به
بعضهم أذنك التي تسمع بها
وما السبب؟
إذا كان في كيمياء بين الـteam
وكان في ثقة وتضحية
وأتكلم عن تضحية حقيقية
ليس أن تترك الإستراحة لأسبوعين متتاليين
إذا ما كانت موجودة
حاول أن تتصرف بطريقة مختلفة
بناء الأفكار هذه وبداياتها
والإنتهاء منها
يصنع تراكم خبرة
يصنع أهداف جديدة
ربما تغيرت الفكرة
إلى أن تصل إلى النجاح
ماهو معنى النجاح؟
في ريادة الأعمال
والـbusiness سهلة
كم الربح.
بكل بساطة.
أرقام
كم دخل عندي؟
كم أنا ربحت الآن؟
لكن في معنى ثاني للنجاح
تعلمته من أشخاص
أحدهم كان عنده مشروع
بدأ فيه بأسلوب تأجيري
في النهاية يوفر وظيفة للشخص
ما ظل المشروع
أخذ منه ممكن سنة
فشل المشروع في النهاية
فلما قابلته
قلت: ما أخبار المشروع؟
قال: والله قُفِل
قلت يعني... أواسيه
ما يخالف، والموضوع بسيط إن شاء الله
ويجي المشروع القادم
قال: لا
من قال لك أني خسرت؟
أنا ساهمت في فتح 3000 بيت
ووفرت 3000 وظيفة
إنه يرى النجاح من زاوية أخرى
لم أكن منتبها لها
أنا كنت أكلمه في الارقام.
النقود.
وهو يلاحظ أشياء أخرى.
أيضا، شخص آخر
فشل في إدارة مشروع
لفترة طويلة
قابلته بعدها
وكالعادة أواسيه
قال: من قال لك أني فشلت؟
أنا الآن إذا بدأت أي مشروع من الصفر
أستطيع أن أعرف إن كان ناجحا أم لا.
مجرد الخبرة
التي جمعها خلال الفترة السابقة.
(تصفيق)
الآن، الخبرات التي تراكمت
والـ exposure الموجود على الإنترنت
نستطيع الحصول على المعلومة ببساطة
العلاقات، صغر السن
القدرة الجسدية والنفسية
دافع لكي تنجح
اليوم الخيارات كثيرة
والأفكار أكثر.
لما جلسنا هنا
نتدرب قبل يومين
كنا نتكلم عن لما لا تصل العلاجات
إلى أصحاب الأمراض المزمنة
التي يأخذونها بشكل دوري
من المستشفى؟
لما لم يبدأ أحد العمل
على هذا المشروع حتى الآن؟
وتكلفته سيارة وجدول.
سواءا كان electronic
أو مجرد أوراق
تكلمنا عن أكثر من فكرة ريادية
ممكن أنها تبدأ ومن الممكن أن تفشل.
لكن تخيل لو نجحت.
النجاح أكثر من هذا.
الآن ماذا بعد؟
كم فكرة مرت عليك في اليوم؟
كم فكرة، كم منتج رأيته وقلت أوف.
كان علي أن أفعله
أو فكرت بها من قبل.
أو أني تخيلت شيء كهذا.
إذا بدأت اليوم ستأخذ الرحلة.
الرحلة صعبة.
بدايتها صعبة.
منهكة.
ممكن تصل كوارث في المنتصف.
لكن في الأخير ستحصل على الخبرة.
فتخيلو معي
10000 أو دعونا نقول 1000 شخص
سيفكر في نفس الفكرة التي فكرت بها
وبالتفاصيل.
معناها فكرت ليس لها قيمة
100 منهم سيبدؤون.
بكتابة على ورقة،
بتصميم نموذج أولى
سيبدؤون.
10 منهم
سيصلون للمنتج النهائي.
واحد منهم ستكون له
الحصة السوقية الأكبر.
فهل تستطيعون البدء؟
هل تستطيعون أن تبدؤو؟
نعم
الله يعطيكم العافية
وهذا العشم، شكرا لكم.
(تصفيق)